Oprah watches 21 heroes are great but
blizzard isn't stopping there more
characters are on the way and we just
got a tease for the newest addition to
the team I'm Tony and this is your
objective based game spot news update
the overwatch Twitter account posted
this picture of what they're calling a
prototype biotic rifle the picture shows
quotes from torbjorn and mercy and the
rifle itself seems to contain parts
similar to torrents turret and mercies
staff this leads many to believe the new
hero will be some sort of healing sniper
possibly the mysterious figure sombra
who's been hinted at a few times in the
game some say it might even be a
codename for farrer's mother on Amar'e I
guess we'll just have to wait for
blizzards official announcement in other
overwatch news the game's competitive
mode is now live if you've reached at
least level 25 you can take on other
overwatch players of a similar skill
level overwatch has only been in the
public's hands for a few months so
expect plenty of announcements down the
road to keep up with everything Blizzard
is working on keep your sights on
gamespot